[Musique]
pourquoi une mission sur les
judiciarisation de la société française
parce que il y à beaucoup de tensions
dans notre société à cet égard je pense
à une première tension entre le monde
politique
et les juges le monde politique en 2021
se méfie des juges et les juges se méfie
du monde politique s'est totalement
malsain un grand principe et nous devons
trouver des éléments dialogue deuxième
élément de tension entre les règles
européennes et les règles nationales nos
concitoyens ne comprennent pas toujours
où est la décision
comment fonctionne la primauté du droit
européen comment elle fonctionne en
matière constitutionnelle
il y aura au mois de janvier au mois de
février à de nombreuses auditions des
auditions aller avec des professeurs de
droit des auditions avec des juristes
avec des responsables des grandes
juridictions de notre pays pour
justement essayer de bien comprendre ce
qui est du ressort du pouvoir judiciaire
ce qui est du ressort du pouvoir
législatif
jusqu'où à la jurisprudence ne fait pas
loi mais s'inspire de la loi qui a été
initialement voter des parlementaires et
puis nous aurons la possibilité d'avoir
des déplacements notamment auprès de
l'union européenne pour travailler sur
ces enjeux de juridictions européennes
et du rapport avec le droit français
avec la loi française
il y a également des choses qui existent
et qui ne sont pas utilisés l'article 88
6 de la constitution l'une des deux
champs prenons l'exemple du sénat a la
possibilité de différer une décision
européenne au règlement une directive
directement devant la corde justice
c'est à dire qu'en matière de
d'application du principe de
subsidiarité
nous pouvons aller beaucoup plus loin
que nous faisons actuellement en résumé
nous souhaitons reconstituer retrouver
une meilleure régulation entre les juges
et le parlement entre les juges et la
société civile les uns et les autres ne
peuvent pas prétendre signoret et être
dans deux mondes différents